welcome to the third installment in
video game movie theme month here on
folding ideas I'm your host the foldable
human as promised this week we're going
to take a look at of Abel's 2007 film
postal postal is an adaptation of the
videogame series of the same name and
it's actually not as bad as you think it
is and don't close the video I've got a
point to make here okay just just just
give me a second before you go thinking
that I've gone completely soft in the
head
no it's not a great movie or even really
a good movie it's got a pretty decent
list of flaws and we'll get around to
those but I do have to say that this
film has been preemptively damned by
association with bowl so let's talk
about it
structured as a satire on post 9/11
America the film follows its nameless
protagonist credited as postal dude
played by all around good sport Zach
Ward as his bad day culminates in the
end of modern civilization our other
major characters are Uncle Dave played
by kids in the Hall alumni Dave Foley a
con artist cult leader and Osama bin
Laden in short postal dude is unemployed
Uncle Dave owns a million dollars in
taxes and Osama bin Laden is laying low
in Arizona dude goes to a job interview
gets caught in a gunfight at the
unemployment office splits a joint with
Uncle Dave they decide to steal a truck
of scrotum dolls that bin Laden crew are
also trying to get their hands on
because the dolls are full of swine flu
there's a Throwdown at a Nazi theme park
avaible gets shot in the dick Verne
Troyer gets kidnapped in his own luggage
they take the dolls back to the compound
find Osama screw ransacking the place
they sneak into the bomb shelter Dave's
assistant Doom's Verne Troyer to be
raped by a thousand chimps an act
foretold in the Bible of Uncle Dave to
bring about the end of days dude gets
thrown in the brig breaks out goes Rambo
there's a big shootout at the trailer
park he blows up his wife than Bush
nukes China and China nukes America
credits roll okay so how does this stand
up is an adaptation all in all I think
it does okay there's plot elements that
are obviously invented for the
but the tone and intent are fairly
similar to the original games the postal
games are already little more than
exploitation esposa tire wear mechanics
and storytelling take a backseat to
sophomoric humor and that carries over
here you have the nameless everyman
protagonist who wanders around playing
out a power fantasy extracting systemic
revenge against all the little
irritations of modern life it's not
exactly sophisticated discourse postal
is not a dissection of how Cavalier
we've become with violence in media it's
a celebration of the it'd and the
insecure male ego that uses a layer of
self-awareness to make the subject
matter funny instead of tragic that's
actually a pretty common theme in video
games particularly shooters from the mid
to late 90s when companies seem to be
locked in an arms race to offend the
general public so as an adaptation of
some lowbrow material it's more or less
accurate
you've got sensationalist humour and
obnoxious bizarre a world of over
exaggeration and gods of senseless
violence but fidelity to source material
doesn't make you a good movie if you
want to be a good movie you still need
to do things well and if you want to be
a good satire then well you've got the
deck stacked against you see satire is
hard really really hard the thing about
comedy is that it needs to look
effortless a good delivery can sell even
a weak joke and a great joke can be
killed by subtle failures in timing
inflection and tone satire takes on an
extra risk of becoming culturally
irrelevant as time passes and that's
where we start running into a lot of
postal flaws to start some of the jokes
are just dated and even in 2007 jokes
about George Bush being a simpleton
we're getting pretty stale also the
timing on a lot of scenes is weak the
best example would be the shootout in
the Nazi themed little Germany the scene
more or less revolves around a gag where
children and for the most part only
children are caught in the crossfire
in concept this should be hilarious
subverting the normal invulnerability of
bystanders especially children in action
movie gunfights but the pacing of the
scene is all off rather than the pace
escalating is the joke Vil
it sticks with its steady opening rhythm
throughout this same pacing flaw comes
up again at the end of the film in the
giant shootout at the trailer park
there's the set up but the events take
too long to escalate to the absurd why
this is a problem is that it gives the
audience too much time to acclimatize to
what's going on giving the impression
the scene is actually being played
straight
in contrast don't be a menace to society
gives us an almost poetic escalation
from normal to the absurd in the scene
outside the guns and liquor store
pump chicks here I'm sure as we gotta
come to pit I said do we have 800 on the
front again
Randy all right fellas game
I said goo we have hey hello huh oh you
yes you yes oh now you better get your
stank asses up out of here [ __ ] was a
nuclear honk us up in here boom let's go
let's go oh come on hey let me Hiroshima
[ __ ] suck this also illustrates
another flaw that permeates the movie
the lack of normal everything in the
film is so obnoxious and the characters
are all so repulsive that there's not
enough contrast for the absurd
in comedy terms there's no straight guy
okay to be fair this is actually just
something inconsistent there's a scene
where he goes for a job interview and
tries to play it straight while the
world around him disintegrates into
insanity last question what is the
difference between a duck
and but this is followed by a scene
where a gunfight breaks out in the
unemployment office and he takes
advantage of the situation by crawling
along the ground stealing chips from the
fallen in order to move up in line the
scenes are still funny but they
establish a baseline that the film often
has trouble rising above leaving a lot
of important scenes trying to write
violence in taboo as their sole joke the
end result is that often it feels like
it's just trying so hard to be offensive
that you just get used to it and tune it
out so let's get back to what I said at
the beginning postal isn't as bad as you
think well there are some legitimately
great moments in the movie the opening
scene where two 911 hijackers argue
about the exact number of virgins
promised them for their martyrdom is
brilliant slowly building from hard
reality into the absurd as they're
informed the deal has changed and 100
virgins has become 10 JK Simmons takes a
throwaway part as a soapbox candidate
and elevates it with a perfect deadpan
Dave Foley is simultaneously at the top
of his game and the bottom of his career
as a con artist who now runs a doomsday
cult and this motivational speaker is a
pitch perfect example of satire it's
extreme enough that you're sure it's
fake but at the same time you're not
sure how surprised you'd be if you saw
this in real life for 72 hours straight
at a time especially if you put crystal
meth in the water now some of you may be
asking isn't crystal meth illegal
technically yes
but the US Air Force uses it to fuel
their pilots were Lerner on night
missions over Afghanistan so it can't be
that illegal that the US Air Force uses
it and of course we couldn't really talk
about postal without talking about
movables cameo as himself because you
know they're all that room was out that
my movies and finance was Nazi good and
what should I say it's true but somebody
must do something with the money and
that brings us full circle
what sunk postal wasn't its quality far
far worse than this has been put out
before what sunk it was association with
avaible personally I don't think he's a
terrible director
I think he's a mediocre director and a
terrible producer maybe he needs to make
more contemporary comedy maybe he needs
to work more with other producers who
can feed him better ideas maybe he just
needs to make more films where he gets
shot in the dick all right next week
we're looking at something worth
watching source code tell me
everything's gonna be okay